اول اختراق في ميدان المعركه منذ سته اشهر
يحققه الجيش الروسي باعلانه السيطره
الكامله على بلده سوليدار التي باتت اكثر
النقاط سخونه على جبهه المعارك في
اوكرانيا
صاحبها مقتل 700 جندي اوكراني وتدمير 300
قطعه سلاح حيث ستسمح السيطره على سوليدار
للقوات الروسيه بقطع الامدادات عن
الاوكرانيين في خطوه تمهدوا لتطبيق مدينه
باخموت وفتح الطريق امام الجيش الروسي
للوصول الى المدن الكبرى في منطقتي دنيا
قياده عسكريه موحده لجيوش مختلفه تضم قوات
دونباس ومرتزقه
الشيشانيه وايضا الفرق المتطوعين
السيطره على سوريا
لطيران الجيش والقوات الصاروخيه والمدفعيه
ومنعت بذلك نقل الاحتياطات والذخيره
واجبرت العدو على الانسحاب لخطوط دفاع
اخرى
تكتسي بلده سوليدار اهميه بالغه
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه الروسيه الجديده
بحيث تعتبر محطه وصول مهمه الى باخ موت
التي تبعد 15 كلم عنها فيما تعطي تلالها
المرتفعه ميزه الاشراف على خطوط الامداد
الاستراتيجيه بين منطقتي لوجانسكو ودونيس
في اقليم دونباس
وباعلان روسيا سيطرتها على البلدا يصبح
تطبيق من الشمال اسهل بكثيره ومن ثم
اختراق اهم خط دفاع رئيسي لاوكرانيا في
جومباسا كما ان ارتياح القوات الروسيه في
المحور الشمالي يجعل السعاده السيطره على
الايمان
سبب اخر على سوليدار محطه انظار الروس هو
احتوائها لانفاق تعدين ممتده تحت الارض
لاكثر من مئه وستين كيلومترا لديها القدره
على استيعاب جلود ودبابات وعربات موشات
قتاليه
المكاسب في سوليدار قابلها تحرك جديد من
قبل الرئيس بوتين مفاده ان العمليات
العسكريه تصبح تابعه لقياده الاركان
الروسيه مباشره والتي جاءت نتيجه مخاوف
كبيره من احتماليه حدوث تصدعات بين القوات
الموجوده في شرق وجنوب البلاد